Well, this particular trend goes contrary to, um,
the wisdom being espoused by people like, uh,
Thornburg and AOC and the apocalyptic
sect within the environmentalist movement.
There are a lot of smart environmentalist who are making very reasonable points,
but the apocalypse within the, uh,
the environmentalist movement are saying that we are going to lose
millions of people to climate change.
The last trend shows the number of people who die as a
result of natural disasters.
These are not things that humanity has any control over.
We are talking about earthquakes and tsunamis and what we have seen,
and I kid you not. And I urge people to go to Trent 10,
is that the number of fatalities due to environmental disasters or other
environmental disasters has declined by 99% of the last a hundred years?
[Inaudible].
I think people will be able to believe this is real,
the long piece that we're actually the Wars of the,
of the last hundred years are, are winding down in reality.
Yes. Um, right now it's, it's actually quite, uh, um, um,
strange to talk about it now,
because we do actually right now had a conflict between two countries and that's
other by John. And,
but what's so interesting about that conflict is that the two countries
didn't declare war on each other. And in fact,
I think that the last time that a country declared war on another was
the Korean war between, uh,
between the United States and North Korea.
And in fact, international conflict,
which is to say to countries that declare war on each other,
and then send armies across borders to slaughter each other citizens that has
pretty much disappeared from the world do have,
we've had an uptick in recent years in, in civil Wars.
So pretty much all the conflicts that are happening in the world today are civil
Wars. There are no longer international conflicts. There are civil Wars,
and there has definitely been an uptick in civil Wars,
but nowhere close to the number of civil Wars that were taking place in 1970s
and the eighties. So even though, yes, we are not at a,
at, at, at a historically low level of conflict,
we are certainly at a much level or a lower level of conflict than we were in
the seventies and the eighties. And that's why you need the long-term data,
because just when you think that things are being bad and that we've lived
through some, I don't know, five years of negative news,
look what was happening in the world in the seventies and eighties, compare it.
And you'll be happy.
That brings us to trend number 10,
which is that we are living in a safer world than we have in a very,
very long time.
Yes. Well, this particular trend goes contrary to, um,
the, the wisdom being espoused by people like, uh,
Thornburg and AOC and, uh, the,
the apocalyptic sect within the environmentalist movement.
There are a lot of smart environmentalist who are making very reasonable points,
but the apocalypse within the, uh,
the environmentalist movement are saying that we are going to lose
millions of people to climate change.
The last trend shows the number of people who die as a
result of natural disasters.
These are not things that humanity has any control over.
We are talking about earthquakes and tsunamis and what we have seen,
and I kid you not. And I urge people to go to Trent 10,
is that the number of fatalities due to environmental disasters or other
environmental disasters has declined by 99% of the last hundred years?
Why would that be? One reason is that as we grow richer,
we are able to build more sturdy dwellings.
So as architecture becomes more resistant to earthquakes,
flooding and so forth, um, obviously fewer people die.
And another thing that's improved is, uh, science. Um,
we have satellites which are able to track the formation of a storm
in the Caribbean.
We can project its trajectory along the coast of the United States.
We can predict its landfall within, you know, a few dozens of miles.
And all of that means is that we gain time to
prepare for storms and hurricanes and tsunamis. Well,
I'll get to tummies in a second and therefore fewer people die,
even when it comes to tsunamis, what do we have now?
We are able to monitor the ocean for, for earthquakes,
which then, uh, sent information by, uh,
sensors to the mainland of Japan saying, for example,
saying that 200 kilometers to the East of,
I don't know, Tokyo, that hasn't been yeah.
And you can expect at tsunami in 36 minutes.
And that means that a lot of people can, can,
can move to higher ground or can prepare or whatever. Yeah.
All right. So those were the top 10 that you guys focus on in the book.
Now I'm going to really challenge you as an author because I am going to
randomly flip to three more. We will finish with three more of the 78,
and let's see if you know what you're really talking about here. So here we go.
All right. Trend 52,
rising natural gas reserves. We've actually got extra gas.
I know we've got a lot of wind bags out there, but we've got extra.
That's right. So before I go there and actually let me say that,
I don't actually know if Tokyo is on, on the Seacoast or not, but nevermind.
We are going to get, I'm going to get a lot of hate mail for that.
But when it comes to gas, what happened was, was extra ordinary.
And that is that in the last, uh, 10 to 15 years,
last 10 years, uh, shale fracking, uh,
has become much more efficient than people ever assumed.
And so a lot of natural gas that was trapped in rocks and you
couldn't get to it.
We can now get to because of superior technology
that people decades ago didn't have.
And so the known reserves of natural gas are now
at a record level.
So in spite of the fact that we've been using natural gas for decades,
we now know of more reserves than ever before.
That has the positive effect, of course,
of driving down the price of natural gas. When you have natural gas,
that is very cheap, you can then use it instead of coal generating electricity.
When you use it instead of coal generating electricity,
you are emitting fewer CO2 emissions into the atmosphere.
Um, so that is shale, uh, that is shell fracking. And, uh,
we are very lucky that in the United States,
we are the center for some of the most innovative minds,
because this is very much an American success story.
There you go. All right, I'm randomly selected here. Here we go. Uh, Oh,
41. This'll be an interesting one.
Nuclear arsenals are actually going down.
Yes. So at the height of the cold war in the mid 1980s,
the United States and the Soviet union had something on the order
of, uh,
20,000 nuclear warheads each aimed at one another.
If those exploded at the same time, it would be over for civilization.
The planet would have been uninhabitable. The end.
What has happened since then, uh,
is that I believe we are down to about 3000 nuclear warheads per
Soviet unit per Russia and per United States. So we have decreased, uh,
the amount, the number of warheads dramatically. Now,
unfortunately in recent years,
there has been some backsliding on these international treaties,
which are regulating how many nuclear weapons the country can possess.
And it's possible that in the future, the number of weapons possessed by China,
India, United States, Russia,
and so forth will start climbing and we should be on top of this.
It is a serious problem.
It is a serious problem because the knowledge that we have in terms
of producing nuclear weapons, that cannot be unlearned, you can in a, in a,
uh, you know, on a shelf somewhere and hope that people will forget about it.
I think that what we should be aiming is having the scientific community,
um,
tell us what would be the minimal number of warheads that
could go off on earth whilst at the same time,
preserving civilization, some semblance of civilization, preserving humanity,
and then distribute that number of warheads or access to those numbers of false
warheads amongst nuclear powers.
So I think we should be going in the opposite direction.
We should try to get nukes as low as possible,
and then have some sort of a, um, uh,
proportional distribution amongst great powers.
That would be a hell of a meeting trying to get proportional distribution.
Well, that'd be four. We've done that before in the 1920s,
the United States presided over, uh, the navel,
this armament between the United States, uh, uh, France,
Britain and Japan, where there was a key, according to which, uh,
Naval warships, uh, juggernauts where, uh, where, uh, sorry,
juggernauts dread notes were distributed amongst, uh, different, great powers.
And, uh, I think it was something like 10, 10, seven, seven, four, four,
depending on the power of the relative power of,
of that great power. But my point is,
we had done this before with what was then the equivalent of a
nuclear weapon, which was the Dreadnought.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversation about the
environment, instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our environment playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.